When I was a little kid, I spent most of my days playing with robot toys,...
...or watching TV shows like "Transformers"...
...where a war re - erupts between two robotic clans,...
...the heroic ones and the evil robots.
Anyhow, my childhood dream was to become an engineer who invents,...
...develops and controls robots.
As a child,...
...I wanted to make a robot that would do my homework and go to class instead of me.
Then you should visit a robot theme park here in Korea.
The government announced that it will build...
...two robot theme parks as part of an effort...
...to boost the country's robotics industry.
Can you imagine?
Those two places will be meccas for the country's robot industry.
They will include amusement park areas,...
...exhibition halls and stadiums...
...where robots can compete in various events.
But you know what I really hope?
I do hope that those robots just stay at exhibition places...
...and not end up out in the real world.
Maybe I watched too many movies that show...
...unpleasant consequences after developing robots.
But I predict that those artificial intelligences...
...will become so human - like in the near future,...
...that who knows, maybe one day,...
...robots might have emotions,...
...you know, feel love, jealousy and hatred.
Do you predict so?
My opinion is somewhat different from yours.
I don't think the robots actually feel emotions like love, joy, and sadness.
Even though technology has been developing quickly,...
...it will not be able to make a system to feel emotions like human beings!
As you know,...
...robots are just moved by a system made by human beings.